one of the most significant discoveries
of the early 20th century was of a part
of the mind we now refer to as the
unconscious
it came to be properly appreciated that
what we know of ourselves in ordinary
Consciousness comprises only a fraction
of what is actually at play within us
and that a lot of what we really want
feel and are is not at our mental
fingertips lying instead in a penumbra
of ignorance fantasy and denial which we
can only hope to dispel with patient and
compassionate efforts probably with the
assistance of an analyst
Sigmund Freud's the interpretation of
Dreams first published in Vienna in 1900
was the landmark study of the workings
of this unconscious region and detailed
the mind's Relentless attempts to hide a
great many of its most Salient truths
from itself in the form of Dreams which
might shock disturb or excite us while
they unfolded but would then be
deliberately forgotten or misunderstood
Upon Our waking at much the same time
700 kilometers to the West over the
Border in Switzerland another pioneering
figure in early psychoanalysis Carl Jung
took a complimentary but more direct and
arguably more robust approach
still only in his late 20s Jung held a
prominent position in zurich's former
psychiatric institution the book hulsley
clinic and it understood that many of
his patients were suffering from
symptoms created by a conflict between
what they deep down knew of themselves
and what their conscious Minds could
bear to take on board about their
feelings and desires
someone might for example lose all
ability to speak because of one or two
things they so longed but were so afraid
of communicating to particular people
another might develop a terror of
urinating because of a humiliation that
they had suffered in childhood but that
they lacked the wherewithal to remember
and process
following Freud Jung believed that
healing and growth required that we
learn to untangle our mental knots and
more fully appreciate our complicated
sometimes surprising yet real identities
Freud had concentrated on interpreting
his patients nighttime visions and in
listening to them speaking at length in
unhampered ways on his therapeutic couch
Jung felt that this took far too much
time and was too much at the mercy of
the right Chemistry Between analysts and
patient so together with his colleague
Franz ricklin in 1904 he developed what
he took to be a more reliable technique
which he termed the word association
test
in this test doctor and patient were to
sit facing one another and the doctor
would read out a list of 100 words on
hearing each of these the patient was to
say the very first thing that came into
their head it was vital for the success
of the test that the patient tried never
to delay speaking and that they strive
to be extremely honest in reporting what
they were thinking however embarrassing
strange or random that might seem
Jung and his colleague quickly realized
that they had Hit Upon an extremely
simple yet highly effective method for
revealing parts of the mind that were
normally relegated to the unconscious
patients who in ordinary conversation
would make no allusions to certain
topics or concerns would in a word
association session quickly let slip
critical aspects of their true selves
Jung grew especially interested in how
long his patients paused after certain
word prompts despite the request that
they answer quickly in relation to
certain words patients tended to grow
tongue-tied unable to find anything they
could say and then protesting that the
test was silly or cruel Jung did not see
this as coincidental it was precisely
where there were the longest silences
that the deepest conflicts on neuroses
lay a literal tussle could be observed
between an unconscious that urgently
wanted to say something and a conscious
overseer that equally urgently wanted to
stay very quiet indeed in a given test
the doctor might say angry and the
patient might respond mother they would
say box and the patient might respond my
life shut in one they might say lie and
the patient would respond brother or
they might say money and the patient
struggling with guilt and shame might go
silent for a very long time before
saying they needed to go and get some
air
Jung and ricklin published their
research in a book called diagnostic
Association studies written in dense
scientific jargon this comprises a
succession of charts about what people
answered in how long according to their
ages classes genders and occupations we
are unfortunately unlikely to learn Too
Much from the book today but the
interest of the underlying test lies
Less in the specific purpose for which
Jung used it than in what it can more
broadly suggest to us about ourselves
when we turn to it in more intimate ways
though it was made for a clinician to
interpret we can ourselves gain a huge
amount from sitting this test on our own
and analyzing our responses and
hesitations according to what we know of
who we are we may be ambivalent about
self-knowledge but we are ultimately
also in a pole position to make advances
in our more honest moments we know
rather a lot about where the bodies are
buried you can find the test in the text
below this film
we can use Jung's hundred words as a
provocative guide to regions of our
experience that we have to date lacked
the courage to explore but that might
hold the key to our future development
and flourishing
of course where we go blank and decide
the test is really very silly well there
we should probably pay the greatest
attention